oh my oh I just spilled poke all over my
keyboard
oh
oh that doesn't seem good Let Me Go full
screen
all right everybody having an eventful
stream here so far guys oh [__]
no no no stop
[Music]
am I still here what the [__] dude
Windows the new windows is wild for that
huh who needs a keyboard anyway Sam says
we're putting you in a home I could use
the support now we're in business thank
you love all right let me flip this on
just hope that it drives narrator
dialogue okay okay but button alt plus
oh heads up heads up heads up narrator
keyboard changes we've updated the
narrator keyboard layouts exiting
narrative narrator let's not let's not
go that route specifically